Chào bạn Ờ
Anh cũng vừa tròn 8 rồi
cả ngày
ở Mỹ từ cạn Chẳng có cái gì tâm sự mấy
Chắc là
tranh thủ trả lời câu hỏi sau đó thì ở à
ở đầu tiên là cái phụ theo tôi nói này
trước đi à
Ừ tôi không biết tôi chỉ với ông về cái
vụ là các phím tắt có thử thứ của cái C
em
có mấy đâu này cho tiện chưa giống như
tôi thực bạn ạ à hai chỗ petition ý
không nhiều không ạ Thôi mở lại nhá Ờ
em
có cái con fix này nó có cái u xơ Adidas
này mổ nó bằng à
a pet này thì tôi đã có a để thay cho
phép với efficient này sau đó thì ghi rõ
là cái gì thì
Em ăn trước mình dùng Ame có để mix màu
đồ thực tế là thực tế thì ăn mà màu thì
nhiều lập trình viên không thì công ty
như công ty ở tôi đang dùng được ạ thì
nó mất mấy cái chân như này cơ cho macro
đồ tại sao như thế bởi vì khi mà Mấy ông
đã có cơ sở dữ liệu trung hòa
khi mà ông về sau không Cốt đấy thì gần
như ông khó mà chuyện thêm bảng mới đó
ít khi rất ít khi thêm ảnh mới nhưng mà
cập nhật bảng cũ thì rất nhiều ngân hàng
ra là cái Make My sân này ngoài việc đào
tạo bằng mới khi nói về enter thì sửa
bản cũ thường tôi sẽ chạy lại ngày rất
nhiều này ngoài ra còn thêm lạnh vì nữa
kiểu may cho chỉ thêm cho mấy ông là ví
dụ là a khái niệm này tội từng đi lâu
rồi hôm nay sao tiện nói hơn nó lại I'll
I a happier này cái này để làm gì ta đầy
cho India tức à mình Cái phần mềm ghép
Porto mấy hepl tới giờ giúp đỡ sau nhận
cái video này thì làm gì để cho nó sẽ
gợi ý cho cho mình Cụ thể là mua đồ
thường là mua đồ để sao cho nó chuẩn hơn
nó sẽ không bảo mấy cái lỗi nữa mới có
lỗi kiểu như này
ừ ừ
kiểu ngay nó nó đang bảo Cái lỗi này nó
rõ là công ty hàng này đúng ạ Rõ là hàng
này có Chẳng qua nó kế thừa từ cái thằng
mua đồ cho Vân Thế làm thế nào để nó báo
lỗi cái này nữa chẳng hại tôi sẽ chạy
thử cho mấy ông nha
ra hay phết I
thường là tôi sẽ dùng lệnh mua đồ như
này Coffee này nha Sửa về trong ngày
Ừ tôi sẽ viết tắt nói IDE như này vào
đây sẽ thay cái này bằng cái mua đồ của
mình là sử trong trường hợp màu users
không ạ Hãy đây là đô la sao nha ấy hiểu
được cả phía sau mình sẽ viết vào trong
ngày nay Ok Thế thế này Đấy bây giờ
Ừ được cái này chạy Xong rồi này đúng ạ
anh khi mà anh sửa xong cái file viết
tắt này thì ông phải phát tại cái á
a comment đô Này ông sẽ refresh lại nhé
restart lại anh sao anh
ờ ờ sau đó thì bây giờ gọi ADM số không
do Nga
Ừ ừ
thường là nó sẽ hỏi thêm câu hỏi nữa đó
là cái file tồn tại thôi Một nó không
biết kiểu khi đè lên hay là ông sẽ viết
vào trong cái file hepl này thì đợi thì
tôi thường không thôi muộn thường mặc
định nó cứ ghi đè lên thì sẽ làm gì tôi
sẽ có cái ạ
đội tôi một tí thôi nhớ có cái Fox là
cập bỏ qua có hỏi đợi Tâm tính
ừ ừ
họ
I read
anh ở đây
luôn ghi đè lên là thêm cái này nữa
ngã đáy hiệu luôn kia lên này lại rồi
restart lại cái này
sẽ viết vào trong cái thằng ngu rô này Ê
mèo
các bạn vào đây này Nó sẽ có
ở những cái hàm này khoe cho thử nhé Nó
sẽ không báo lỗi cái hàm quay nữa rồi
tôi một tí nha à
à à
lỗi nó chọn và thỉnh thoảng nó sẽ nó sẽ
còn gợi ý cho ông hàm này bạn rất là sợ
chuyện cái gì ở trong này
phần cập nhật tổ chức
có vẻ là nó phải thêm trước quay Vì mới
nhất nhưng mà nó sẽ thông báo cho ông
đây nó sẽ có ý là ông cần được truyền
thì sáng này còn nếu mà Xóa hẳn cái ID
này Xóa hạt cái đi
thế này
thì ông xem lại nha
thì nó sẽ mất cái màu đi
anh mất kệ
chị Thu Cho biết được Tôi nhớ đại khái à
ở đại khá là nó thêm cái đoạn này ở đây
được có cái màu này
A
và không phải là mỗi thêm màu này cho
vui đâu Cái này sẽ có lợi ở điểm gì tôi
sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông về cài stop
stop của cái thằng uzair là cái thằng
mua đồ Ừ cái Scope thì ông sẽ thấy cái
ide-helper là rất có tác dụng hiện tại
không thấy là thử ta tưởng như thế nào
chỉ đổi mỗi màu nhưng thực ra không về
sau tôi dậy Nếu người scot vậy thì ông
sẽ biết được có tác dụng là lâu nha Và
đây là con hay báo rất nhiều cái nữa nó
đọc cái database của ông để biết được
cái thằng này có những cuộc gì nhá Vân
Cầu gì nó có lợi đấy chứ không phải là
kiểu ngoài việc đổi mỗi màu cho vui đâu
À
hôm nay sau cũng muốn 14 mạng này
em thấy á á
áo kiểu hôm trước tâm sự lên 100 hôm nay
ô hay hôm nay có đá bóng kìa
ông về crm này cái cm này nếu mà ông
không biết thì nó là kiểu dạng này là
cái trang để quản lý nó là cái trang của
bên admin lý nó thường để quản lý khách
hàng gì đó ngay khỏi khách hàng đây là
người mua hàng đâu nó lại khá là tra
quản lý ở bến amin rồi đặt tên là Cm
thôi nhớ như thế nhớ hết
thì ví dụ hôm nay tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy
ông à bên
khi bạn mua rồi không
anh
bảo Trang thì nó sẽ kiểu hình thì ra đó
boss như thế này không ạ bây giờ sẽ hiển
thị ở ozo này rồi các thứ nó chưa có này
bay lên đây ai nhỉ
Ok tạm bỏ qua đi Nó nằm ở trong một file
cố định rồi sửa nó vẫn dễ đầu tiên là
bây giờ mình cứ
Anh làm bên trang admin mình sẽ phân
biệt những cái Vinamilk rồi cái khách
hàng các thứ ra toàn bộ vì trên Zalo này
tí mình phải Tống nó chỗ nào nó phù hợp
vì làm đến amin mà không ạ Đầu tiên là
tôi sẽ tắt muốn là bấm vào cái đường
Linh ở đây chẳng hạn thế Đợi tí nhé
xài 3A
anh
béo nhìn này ghê không Cái này chưa có
truy vấn của tôi ở bên ở hồi đó bán bột
đấy à nhầm thôi làm phần mềm ra trường
đấy
không biết được hồi đợi tôi làm trong
lăng nhăng phức tạp nha à
Ê mai luôn đi
anh alo mở cả thư mục đích của các nước
Ê mày sau có đi bán Trinh à
những bài kể chuyện đó là
cây body nhà
em copy đá với này
cần chuẩn Huyền
mà có kiểu giảm cân chính trái phải ở
lại
a Huấn Nguyễn
ờ ờ
chờ
huyền nghe được như thế này mới được
nghỉ à
em ăn Xuân huyện Hà đấy
ở đây thôi à à
à à
những
logo này
đi xóa lại đi này à à à
ừ ừ
định cho bỏ đi cho không sao đâu ạ
a cimino Xperia e
thế
này có có thêm cái dưới à anh chỉ có gì
ở dưới đó nhỉ à
Ừ
đợi tí cái đoạn này Google Google ở đây
có
à à
cái này đi
Chúng tôi cần một cái lợi bình thường
cái nhảy đến bình thường ký kết
sống thẳng lại K hyper cũ
say
Anh bình thường phải bấm vào đây Như
kiểu như này nó nhìn ra mà mới hay chứ
ngon
ai tuần này số thẻ ra mình thường ok ok
em
nè cái để hiển thị các chỉ số chỉ số gì
đó mình thích thì mình thể làm không thể
bỏ qua sẽ trồng ngay tôi sẽ ở đây sẽ là
Ozil đúng không ạ giờ ngay
này với thể này mình sẽ mở cái file word
mà lên này
cho mấy bạn hôm trước nói về bụng biết
được quay biết the way mình khá nhanh
thôi thì chỉ cần kiểm tra
out không ạ nhưng mà mình chưa phân
quyền gì cả à mà quan trọng là thế nhưng
chưa phân quyền ở đây thì
thôi tôi nhớ lại một tí nhá Đợi tôi một
tí
a lot in
nhà thuốc chưa biết được à
ừ ừ
à
Anh ơi mẹ tôi thử bêđê cái thằng đã đăng
nhập đi copy này sang bên log in
ừ ừ
ý cho đăng nhập bằng kỹ hạn rap được rồi
a
lot in Sign in with
em nghe nhầm đấy ai phải log in with nào
mới được
anh mới đúng
bố mẹ để Shine khó chữa
ném là log in with ở đây thì mình sẽ
không phải or object mà mình sẽ làm như
thế nào mình sẽ
Ừ mình vẫn sẽ điều hướng về nhưng ở đây
mình sẽ kiểm tra đã mình kiểm tra ở đây
là trong trường hợp à
em không có first a-class này nữa kiểm
tra là nó trả về cái data người dung nếu
mà là trùng email Đúng rồi Nếu mà chung
email giống như hôm trước mình làm đấy
mình chỉ đơn giản là kiểm tra nếu mà
trùng Email thì mình sẽ sẽ làm gì đó Vừa
Hòa Vân
nữa à Không điều hướng về đăng ký nữa
Nếu là sự có thì không điều hướng hãy
chọn là như thế
nếu thế tôi phải sửa lại một tí đây là
u nang u xơ này
free
anh
bằng data
i gotta get email này
ạ sau đó đi first lấy thằng đầu tiên về
If ít luôn tức là nếu không có thì mình
sẽ
thì mình sẽ tạo nó mình sẽ có ros
ừ ừ
khi nêm bằng
thế này
Ừ nếu mà không có
à à
khi sex
nêm này
Ừ thôi ta à
gọi mày ông gọi cho cậu hàm kiểu như này
này ông sẽ à
ở Hà Nội ông phải que cái này một phát
nữa cho ông sẽ gọi lại nhưng mà nó sẽ bị
nhược điểm mà ông nó nó sẽ không cập
nhật vào cái thằng đối tượng user này
của mấy ông nghe Thường mấy ông muốn cập
nhật luôn đối tượng user này thì mới
truyền ở dưới này này chúng sẽ nên làm
như này đâu giờ
bằng như này cơ khởi tạo đối tượng kể
ngày
Ê bà thứ là nếu mà Cách Cách mà cho nó
trông nó đơn giản hơn một tí thì ông có
thể gộp hai cái này lại làm một
cho anh chết là mẹ thằng này cũng ở
crete hàng ngày cũng chịu update cũng
chạy lên làm sếp như thế này tôi thường
là tôi có thể nộp Cái này lại là một sẽ
là như thế này ở
ừ ừ
Ừ mình không cần em nữa Mọi ngày luôn
bày xử lý Tức là sao kiểm tra nếu mà
chưa có đúng không Thì mình sẽ tạm tháng
mới do mình sẽ truyền email và như thế
này sau đó thì mình
mình cũng cập nhật nêm cả vào ta trọng
lượng người dùng đã đổi
nêm vào ta ở trên mạng xã hội đấy giáo
xứ Huế cho mình lưu lại
cho hàm xếp này có cái giờ hai đó là à
nó sẽ kiểu Tao sẽ ăn luôn fb hoặc cả
Insert tùy từng trường hợp của mấy ông
ra tiện
à nhưng mà cuối cùng điều hướng về cái
trang này không đúng lắm
a = a
Số
Phone này mặc định cho cái dép bằng chu
vi
Ừ
Vậy thì đợi tiếp sau đó thì ở đây mình
sẽ là ít
trách Enrique là kiểm tra nếu mà tồn tại
rồi thì mình sẽ điều hướng về trang chủ
chẳng hạn Nếu sử đăng nhập xong nhớ đăng
nhập rồi Ờ
Ừ
đợi tí ở đây mình sẽ có cái trang này
rất hay sử ra chỗ khác nhé
ạ trà xanh vào cam sự thế
thì mình sẽ gọi đến với này là welcome
Còn nếu không thì mình sẽ điều hướng thì
trang đăng ký Tức là sao đây kiểm tra
mặc định cứ cho nó là đúng đi còn nếu mà
chưa chưa tồn tại thì mình sẽ để là sai
sau đó đi mình sẽ điều hướng về cha đăng
ký anh còn thường này sẽ điều hướng về
trang Web Cam thử ngay ok đấy tôi nghĩ
về được
anh nghe do tại sao này
Em bấm vào đây nè
cha mẹ ông thấy là tôi sẽ điều hướng về
cho cô cắm đúng không ạ Còn nếu Giả sử
mà tôi xóa cái tài khoản này đi rồi thì
cách xóa tài khoản
Euro hiểu gần nhất ở đây đi xóa 42 đi
làm ạ
Ừ đúng rồi tôi ấn đăng nhập bằng này thì
nó sẽ nhảy sang trang đăng ký ok chưa
Đấy chính là sửa mật khẩu 123 này sạp
này Ok đăng ký thành công rồi này Đấy
Xong bây giờ quay lại trang đăng nhập
này Đầu tiên thì công ty lên rồi đó
ngoại bấm lại vào nữa này thì nó sẽ nhảy
với cái Chồng cô cong nó đại khái xử lý
ở như thế
ờ ờ
Bây giờ thì mới Ông thấy à
Ê nó lấy ra được cả mình sẽ lấy ra được
cái dô dô ở đây mình quý pro là gì nhỉ
Mình ký ức Grow phía trước nhỉ Nhưng mà
rồi trí nhớ rối kỹ năm Zalo mà đấy à
không là ăn Min hay cái gì đó mặc định
mình là một tức à là người
ở người người gì đó nhỉ Đợi tí Nếu thế
thì da mình có form đăng nhập thì phải
là form a a
hai vợ chồng tý nhé vẫn hơi Quay lại cái
bên em đang đăng nhập không Mình không
làm like were vì bị chưa dùng bao giờ
đợi thì vẫn là xoay quanh cái bên Đăng
nhập tại sao Vì tôi muốn cho
ờ ờ
người dùng đăng nhập chính xác là Hồ
router khác hoặc là một cái độ thường là
một cái sắp domain khác ra thế cốt có
thể vẫn trò người đây nhưng mà ý thôi à
cho về một cảnh sắc lung linh khác thì
xui rõ về tôi tạm thời để nó là quý
khích nhé sẽ để nó một cái Foody
khi mà vào thế kỷ mấy ông có thể tạo một
cái file riêng để làm điều đấy
dễ hiểu mà giống kiểu file word đ.tp rồi
sẽ một file phải an minh.tp này một file
đợi một file kiểu application african
chấm tpp-11 phihack rồi chấm TP để hiểu
được rồi cả được file đấy router xoay
quanh vụ
dịch vụ nào đấy hạ thế
em chưa bây giờ nếu đăng nhập như thế
này đăng ký này chị ra mình không biết
được à người này là người nào đúng không
Này nhà Dũng hay gì đó
Ừ mình lên cục chung phòng nghỉ tôi để
tôi không muốn cậu chúng Phong đâu bởi
vì đăng nhập xong thì cũng điều hướng
người ta xanh cái Trang ở bên nhà Tuyển
dụng chứ không phải là trang của
em nấu hiểu tôi không
khi còn đương nhiên là bây giờ mình
không nói chuyện đăng ký biến thành
admin rồi
chỉ có mình vào sữa tao bay ở mình biến
ăn Min thôi chứ đăng ký không có chuyện
vào ăn Min
xe ô tô một tí nhá Ừ
anh ở đây mình sẽ xử lý bài toán nó sẽ
là
ừ ừ
nhưng quan trọng mà
mình đôi Nhưng chắc chắn mình sẽ check
theo lợi level rồi nhưng ý anh à Lúc mà
đăng đăng ký này ta sử Bây giờ anh muốn
có kiểu giả Sarah lean như này chẳng hạn
ngon cái trang cậu ngay sau đó thì nó
mấy cái nút vừa rồi vẫn có thể vẫn có
vẫn giống hệt thế chẳng hạn cứ tạm thời
cho vẫn thể thế nhưng khi bấm vào ấy nó
sẽ đưa Hướng điều hướng ở đây là nó điều
hướng nhảy sang bên trang khi mà đăng
nhập thì anh thì anh cong ấy mặc định
level sẽ rồi luôn và nó sẽ điều hướng
sang trang của
kiểu hát rồi đăng bài luôn Chẳng hạn như
thế con với người dùng thì sẽ điều hướng
hơn Hà Nội dung kiểu như thế
có giống không
phải à
em sửa lại ở bên đăng ký và mình sẽ thêm
cái select một cái salad Hoặc cùng cái
chết Bóp chết bóp cho đơn giản
là kiểu bạn là bạn là hát pro hãy bạn là
gì đúng không Nhưng sẽ ổn hơn
đầy là
tên Blade 2 pro này để mà lại tắt máy đi
rồi
không
kia không Chưa chưa cần phải cái đấy
hi hi
tất cả cái này là ok ok
có ai sẽ là Custom eli này Em đổi cái
nay
Ê bà
ừ hát đi cần
đây sẽ
ở đây mình sẽ có Zalo nó là bằng 1
ờ ờ
thế mấy ai nữa hết rồi à
Ừ cái này là I have
a lô là 2a
Ừ nó
vụ án bé Na
khi đã đăng nhập bằng hai cái đều không
được tôi tạo xóa này đi phát nữa này
ừ ừ
Em bấm vào này
đi xe kéo điều hướng đó mặc định Điền
một cái trước đi mặc định điểm một cái
mình sẽ là sẽ tích cực này đấy à
Ai Cập nhật này nhờ chiếc cực chứ không
phải xây tịch
à à
em có chơi nha ok chưa đăng ký thì mình
bản chất là mình sẽ truyền cái nền pro
ngoài lên đương nhiên là các bạn phải
pha bếp Đoạn này đoạn này phải bà hết
các thứ thứ cẩn thận ở
anh ở đây sẽ
mình sẽ
có rảnh đâu ạ Euro ở đây mình lấy từ
cũng được cho xe Vios
với rô gì cũng quan trọng gì không Họ
đăng ký sai thì họ đăng ký lại họ và cập
nhật các thứ thôi
không biết được họ có là rô cả hai thấy
không thôi à
em mình tính á thì đợi gì
Ừ rồi
Nội vụ Audi
Ừ vậy thì tôi đang định bảo là nếu anh
sẽ viết tắt theo kiểu ngày nữa này
ờ ờ anh cu VP station
em hết á
máy quét
ạ sau đó thì đô la
Vì sao Nga
Ừ ừ trả lại
là out chéo ở đặt tên hay
thế này à
em rửa tay nó là Miss tinh và đấy sẽ
thêm chữ vì quét như này
ở đây và ông ông bạn lười không cho tôi
không biết tắt sự đấy thêm chữ v quét
nhẹ được
Em không biết được không nhỉ con biết
viết liền được không mà thôi với kiểu
này cho tụi mình
Ừ
tôi sẽ tạo một cái file đi quét để mà
kiểm virus
Ừ mình đê bên web này
Anh quay mấy thằng Nhiều nhỉ Tạo xóa đâu
ngoài điện
tin tức là mình không dùng làm mai nữa
thì mình sẽ phải làm lại được mới hết mà
đặt tên là vô nghĩa
ở đây
chợ hoa đầu tiên là mình mình phải là
Chu nghĩa mặc định mình cho là bỏ qua
out bởi vì mình đang đăng ký mà làm sao
mà đã áo được không ạ ạ tiếp theo là
ờ ờ
buộc password ông ạ
Ừ bắt buộc 3 Phú Quốc nè gì đó buộc phải
điền này cái gì đó
a
white nó bắt buộc phải điền này chả thế
Nó không ạ xong rồi nó là string này
còn gì nữa sẽ cậu nhỏ nhất là bao nhiêu
ký tự thì hạn thế nin là không ngờ lại
mắc là bao nhiêu ký tự sẽ ăn thế mắc của
ông mắc của tôi ở đây nó sẽ là hai trăm
nữa nhá
Khi nào đi qua này sau đó thì à
Anh chỉ được phép nằm trong cái danh
sách này
là được
thì mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ là
Ừ tôi sẽ ghi đây làm nha
ông muốn làm với cậu ngay phẩm này xong
rồi nối tiếp là hết rồi nha Nhưng mấy
ông thấy nó sẽ có nhược điểm về giả sử
Gia Phương thứ ra về sau chắc là không
nói chuyện cập nhật thêm rô phi Giả sử
nếu có cần nhấn ra ông lại phải từ ngày
tiếp nó không hay đối ngoại giờ đây tôi
sẽ làm cho cậu khác nếu ông từng thấy
rồi nó rung ai thì sẽ gọi đến Hà Min Ah
em im đúng nhỉ
Ừ ngồi im
ạ sau đó thì ở đây là mà
thế này copy đấy à
em hết rồi à cho nó mấy ông thấy cái nào
thú vị hơn rõ ràng cái dưới hơn ông chỉ
cần topic cái này trông sửa đây Hay vì
ông sẽ thể đăng ký kết theo dòng như này
không sửa lại thêm một cái gì đó mới cái
tôi không thích kiểu chuỗi cửa ngay lắm
Tôi thích kiểu dạng nhìn ngay cho tương
mấy cái
Ừ thế này chắc chắn là người dùng nhập
người dùng khi mà vào thì mình sẽ cậu
ý
tưởng này cho thuê mạnh cho đỡ hơn đỡ
thông báo lỗi tích kiểu nhảy hay không
thể bấm cái lỗi gì nữa Ok đó
ạ bây giờ chắc chắn là kể cả khi mà
người dùng có cố vào để mà gọi là hack
cái chai một mình đi chăng nữa giờ sự là
đổi lại cái ở đây đổi lại cái nó thấy ở
đây có value được ngọn đồi ở đây là
không Hoặc là một hoa cà mưa ấy mà chủ
Xem đăng ký với tư cách hấp ăn Minh được
không ấy thì gọi không được kiểu gì sẽ
quay ở đây báo lỗi không ạ
thế này
mình chưa dùng
mình sẽ là
Ừ có gì này
à à
Mẹ nó bây giờ mới không được đấy à
Khi người vợ Đăng ký sớm mất
Ừ vậy thì gọi tí nhé
ở đây sửa lại đây nha tôi đội này không
đúng không
họ lập tức quay trở lại ngoại đến ngờ
trở lại kèm lỗi mà chúng làm đoạn này
đang ngắm bạn làm tỉ mỉ làm nhà Face
không ạ sẽ kèm lỗi gì đó
ở công ty Trang anh đi Ở đây vài đến này
a medicine and
I explains Euro
đi học đi đoạn này là được
Ừ nó ở trên cái à
ừ ừ
đi à ừ ừ
ông bên emminh ngọn có nhiều đăng nhập
xong rồi
Khi bữa nay lô mình cứ cho là không đi
sự không nhé
em sợ không
tra là nếu không thì mình sẽ điều hướng
về cái trang là các hạ không ạ Cái bên A
ngoài mình sẽ kiểm tra vụ đấy này
ở bên cao Cam để hạn wacom đây mình sẽ
phải đến cái á rô của nó để welcome thì
bên này tôi nhận sự sửa lại ở đây một tí
ừ ừ
khái niệm router group nhưng lại được
này hoặc à như tôi bảo là ông thể tạo
thành file mới
Ừ mai mới ở đây này phải mới ở đây nó có
cái fix cũng là một cái hay nhớ Thế nhớ
nó có cái vụ ở đây là a folder này
v.rohto này cho ông
a group cậu nghe này
A Perfect là api hiệu người từ đâu đến
file tôi trao tôi bắt chước kiểu như thế
luôn nhé
em gửi xe ở đây sẽ có một cái là
anh quý khách là amin
a Matter Where mAh Min
ở đó thì mình sẽ gọi đến cái file admin
đ.tp lại
Ừ ok chưa ạ à
luôn
D3 miệng sẽ rô tơ giúp như bình thường
hay thôi
em ở nhà à à
nó này
ý thì cái điều hướng điều hướng câu vợ
bảo vừa nãy cái cái điều hướng ở bên a a
bài này thì ông có thể ông lấy cá rô của
cái người dung dozer này
Ừ Đấy ông ông Thiện lấy Cá rô nó này sau
đó thì ông truyền vào trong cái này ở đó
anh không khuyến khích kiểu nhà lắm
Nhưng mà nếu có sửa ông chắc chắn là có
cá rô cho Tưng có fix cho từng cái kiểu
ngay rồi ông trên ba để tôi thử đăng
nhập nhé
đang lại lấy à
anh không nhã Bin
ý
tao nói là giá trị không lấy amin của
nhà
Ừ cái này là chữ những chữ viết hoa
cái u dơ
Ừ đợi tao một tí
- 5
ạ sau đó thì ghét
em mua ba lô này
chị sẽ có
a lô a di
đà kinh
ai cho mày không xem nhé
à à
à bấm lại
chị sẽ nào chữa amin
này phải có những cái ha mà nó nghỉ Hàm
được mấy từ form below
để ra được xem này
từ hôm kia này cũng ra được xem này
sẽ lại ghét kia rồi đây
do đó nếu sẽ lấy thấy lấy được ra amin
ông ạ
ở đây sẽ là
à Không này để lấy ra được chưa amin
mình sẽ là xinh toolwiz là để mà lấy
ô
chữ ăn mì Không biết hoa
Ừ cứ lằng nhằng đăng nhập
à à
ở lại
biết hoa này rồi chuyền vào trong này
nữa song
Ừ cái này nó Bác phải bảo router mày
không tồn tại nó rủ rõ là tôi khai báo ở
bên nhà Ông thấy vừa rồi thức khai báo ở
bên
này rồi Như này rồi thích cái như này
Bí quyết ở đây là tôi phải thêm dấu chấm
a a không biết tự quay
Ừ đúng rồi tối thiểu phải lên cho nó hỏi
sao lên cho nó truyền nó nó trước nhà có
thêm cho chấm em trước đấy hiểu à amin
chấm welcome nó phải như thế này
Ok ngoại giao tôi sẽ
nêm hệ add
Ừ đúng rồi em ạ cũng được
năm 2011 đã sửa lại cái này tí phân loại
the way là không tồn tại tôi nghĩ thể rõ
ràng làm thì cũng không biết được đâu ẩn
nó đi nó sẽ đứa con lỗi nhé
tôi khai báo biết được quay này nhưng rõ
lắm mới được em không tồn tại đúng không
ạ thì làm cái mới được quay này đôi
Nhưng mà mình sẽ làm ở trong này thôi
thì mình sẽ hoặc make midway không ạ Tôi
thường sẽ mất một cái gì đó sẽ dọa em
xong rồi bằng pp petition xong rồi make
sống hay chậm nhai Đôla
anh như này đấy hiểu là mình sẽ rách một
cái gì đó cũng là một lệnh viết tắt thôi
ngoại lại tôi chỉ hết cho mấy ông cách
để lười như tôi viết tắt Con Thứ
An này mấy k
à à
ở gần đây sẽ cách làm cái đúng
để thử xem được nhé Ở admin
Little wet
à à
Nghe có vẻ được cách này nhận tiện ông ạ
anh giờ đây mình sẽ sửa lại một tí đây
là mình sẽ đầu tiên à bắt buộc phải au
nóng lạnh mình sẽ bắt buộc ở đây là
Ừ
ok không phải này
I eat
Anh check play kiểm tra đã đăng nhập Hay
chưa Đó Ngoại ạ
ở những nhà sữa chưa mình sẽ điều hướng
xe điều hướng quay trở lại trang nào đó
mô tơ này mijack này
ạ sau đó đi quay trở lại sang router là
Trang bên A Lot in kiểu này chẳng hạn
đăng nhập ngoại
are
in user như thế này pro khác
A5
à mà Army II chị sẽ điều hướng kiểu ngay
nhà Ông thấy là tôi dùng bao giờ bằng
cho chắc chắn thường chúng ta nên dùng
bao giờ bằng để mà kiểm tra nó kiểu dữ
liệu chuẩn nữa ở như thế này
tôi lại thử đăng nhập lại phát Đấy
chị sẽ đây là đăng nhập lại
Ừ đợi tâm tí
à à môi mình cho khai báo nếu mà nếu mà
ông ứng dụng biết the work in mày không
sẽ phải khai báo
302 gọi thẳng am in the way nghỉ tí nhớ
hôm trước mình chơi trò là mình gọi
thẳng An Minh với vai trò này được không
cần phải khai báo à trồng cây nen kiểu
như này nữa không cần phải khai báo Nó
là kiểu
nữa Không cần à
I miss the weather
ốp lát
giả
tại sao mình bị bong ra đấy
chứng tỏ bị Băng bị văng ra
ao mình có vẻ đang không không kiểm tra
chuẩn Đợi tí nào nếu mà không Hoặc là
khác điều hướng
a How to other
có
virus không
gọi pro
are you today thử thằng này đi
à à
khi sex
rõ ràng là mình Download in nỉ tức à mày
Có bác nói này
lại đi
anh gọi sau ở midway nè
cho tôi tôi chưa kiểm tra vụ biết rồi
quay về out rồi không rõ lắm
đội tông tí để tí nữa à
anh xóa liền à
em có một tháng này nằm nhập Đây Rồi
A
Happy kênh sâm
hi how're vẫn gọi được
Ariel me the way out rõ nhất
em đợi đi Đợi thì cái này là sử dụng với
gì đấy make out này you can pick out yêu
mình chưa từng dùng micloud
ra làm sao được về sau bởi chiến tranh
của mình vì con sắp luôn mới được
đề kiểm tra
cái góp này tức à mình kiểm tra Quyền
kiểu dạng là cái cửa cái cổng ấy cộng
cho từng hoàn vĩnh hằng
này mà dùng cái này đúng không
Dock in là cái có sẵn của bên số
sibylline mà
thứ ngày
A và lưu lại luôn cẩu rơi internet để
mình lưu lại nhiều dữ liệu
Anh ở trong người dùng
ừ ừ
đã bảo tôi chưa dùng cái này bây giờ tôi
phải mong Tí à
a a đây à
ở hồ password user
anh
ở đây đây đây
các chuyên đề an ninh thế không cần biết
được web nào còn biết được quay ở trong
trường hợp này
chị Thu Nghĩa
ở đây mình sẽ là
thôi
A và
ờ ờ ờ
a ly kason
hồ ly cánh áp Nichkhun Nichkhun à
à à
3 cách đổi thử xem mã password
có bồ bật của thi sat
ừ ừ
- forget password user
không dùng biết được mẹ đi
Ừ thôi à
anh xóa game What's the Word in
tôi sẽ thủ dùng ở đây ở tôi sẽ dùng mà
à à
Ừ cái à gót kia đi
là tại sao tại điện này 5.8 này ờ
anh đại thế
nhận diện được à nhắn nhỉ
a a đây đây
ở nhà làm gì để biết được thầy Ha men
nghỉ tí nhé tí nhé
ừ ừ
trong đây này
thi công sơn rồi Custom
their Mambo không
anh gửi tin nhắn vào đây tạo một cái mới
rồi
ừ ừ
ý theo dõi này lắm rồi
Oh jik nè
anh như bình thường rồi nhỉ Như cái mình
vừa làm thôi
Woa chưa ạ
à à
A Group
a a white
I hope And Seek a rồi
anh ở nhà rồi thì khác gì ấy nhỉ
à à
anh
vẫn quay lại từ đây ạ Cái gì mẹ về đây
nói chuyện làm gì
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
à à
cho tôi lại phải là bạn phải kia rồi
em
sửa lại đây nè anh admin
are you the manor II
la la mà
ờ ờ bêđê out đ vị trí
chị xem được nha
à à
Ừ đợi tí nữa thì đăng ký
ừ ừ
nghe tôi không biết đủ
thì chả tôi màu cái đoạn này sau đi Ừ
tôi sẽ mua đoạn này sau
Ấn Độ lại cô dâu thì làm được nghĩ thế
ừ ừ
sao nói điều hướng về đây nhỉ
Ừ nó chạy qua đây trước à
à à
đây chứ
nó chạy có lấy trước này và đây
sau khi quét expect cái gì đấy chịu bây
giờ đang mặc định Mà nó thôi
anh
ở đây mình sẽ
10 điều hướng về đâu đó
để kiểm tra lâm đã đăng nhập ấy chưa thì
nó rõ là nó cho đăng nhập thì gì cả sai
rồi
I
eat or này nó ngon
phụ trách này
à à
em chưa có thì mình sẽ Hà Huy tơn tô log
in in
Ừ chắc hai trào vệ sinh mà mình sẽ D
ở đâu
chết ở đây đúng không
Lại nha
yêu cầu phim
nụ hôn này kéo rõ ràng tôi có đăng nhập
rồi tôi qua đây mà thôi qua đây log in
để đăng nhập mà
ừ ừ
black mề đay nó bị mất à Không mất được
sau này check này thêm một ở đây nữa để
ennis số 1 cho mày không xem nhé
bà nó qua cái Daughter này qua router
này thì nó qua ngày mấy cái thứ này
à Xong rồi nó qua cái find
à à
cho nó qua đến Mỹ được quen này không
hiểu sao nó không gọi được đến cái chết
ở đây
ạ Con chắc là là truyền áo vào trong này
rồi
các bác kiểm tra hộ đâu rồi Ở đây đây
đây grab đây rồi à đây cá này suốt tiêu
này à
I grabbed đây này ok
nguyên đi tôi tôi tôi tôi nghĩ là đoạn
này không cần phức tạp về đâu cứ nghĩ là
tôi đã hình dung ra được cái này Thôi
đợi tôi một tí Đợi tôi một tí
anh nghe nhạc à
anh nhìn nha
tôi đè không thành phố Rider God
I mean
ở đời nhưng không cần phải nhà đâu với
lời chị này thôi oh rô này thằng Cát này
mới quan trọng này bên này
mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ sửa lại cái bên
này nếu đăng nhập vào ok này ngon
bộ phim sẽ ra rạp ở đây luôn là như thế
này đây đồng hồ trong mày
thì mình sẽ có cá rô ở đây này
Em hãy solo
xong rồi Như này
đó là nó tin một cái get nào Zona đỏ như
này
Ừ nó tối về hình dung Model đấy
Ừ cái đậu sát
đợi lại đi đấy
và biết được wear-out amin
à à
á nhon
em gọi cho mày chết anh nhá đây đi
Outlast nhá à
à à
nghĩa thẩm mỹ được quay lại không hề
kiểm tra được của đây nãy được gọi ai Có
được không nhỉ cái nhỉ
anh em
xz7 góp
khi sex
mì đấy anh ạ
ăn tại thằng ăn Minh ở đây i
xếp hàng ngày đúng không
vi phạm thằng đây đúng không
à à
đi được nha
em đổi đây là our hạn sao ạ Em mệt á bắt
đầu Mệt lắm
Anh Đức
nhảy vào
có tỷ lệ phí ở đây đúng không
ở đây
em BD thằng
outline bản chất là thằng Audi cũng
không còn
không còn được thì làm sao mà chết được
nghỉ áo dễ nghỉ à
những điều thật sự đấy
anh hay gọi đùa giết tao mới được nghỉ
Sao lại nghỉ ngơi mình có nhiều lắm mà
để Focus
từ nãy rồi nó không hiểu vào cái get này
Ừ nó để tôi thử copy rồi hả Đã
vào anh đang đi
bí ẩn ở đây
log in này nó sẽ phải sang bên A này ok
Ừ anh đây
năng đăng xuất đi
đang xuất nha Thì vậy
bí mật ong fake muối mỏ ra hình sự ngày
a
note Ao này à
anh đọc out
Ừ cái không có tóc em mình không dùng
Chó Ken Tôi nhớ chị này được
này
thì
nó phải là a ghost file ảnh
vào web nhỉ
cho nên nó là
Á Đù
Ừ tôi bắt ông phải đưa đấy em
không xem nhé
nhỉ à
Em email
tên này đúng không ạ
chụp lại cho
xe tem
à à
có ai chỉ cần lót em nha
ở lại nhé
ở nhà hơi sai sai à
à Hay là do ở tôi copy cái này xong tôi
phải xóa về anh ấy nhé
Hồ Xuân Thu Rider Den O
[âm nhạc]
please contact us
Thu Thủy đi về phòng
này sẽ ra mẹ đi sân
này em môtô và 2 giờ 3 rưỡi nhưng một số
3 thôi Ờ cái clip này em này à
ờ ờ
A lô tô clear Xóa hết toàn bộ mọi thứ đi
Xóa hết
Ừ chắc là hiện trạng
anh quay lại mày
em chịu à
cô gái thì tôi sẽ lợi Ô Buồn sau vậy xem
ảnh
chỉ đường cho biết rồi mẹ không yên tâm
không khách không bùn gì à
vì vậy muốn mọi mới phết tắt này được
khó chịu ngoài vẫn chưa xong cái tính
năng gì đậu xanh ngồi mỏi mệt quá
quay nhá
anh tặng tính sau đã sửa bạn chẳng làm
cái gì
về New Giờ này tôi sẽ cần bấm vào bên
bên này có
ba mẹ em pin rồi
chị sẽ có một cái newsar nữa đúng thường
giống như tao từng chỉ với ông nó gửi
xuộc cái gì đó nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ
không làm với cậu vì xuống nữa tuổi ông
bà Chúng ta không chơi vì xuống ở đây
à à
em có một cái
quá chuyểnchuyển nhà ở
Gì Đây là à
anh nộp từ ghép
Ừ
đợi thì mình sẽ tạm một cái maicon solo
ở đây
chéo u xơ
cho lâu
nhớ không lầm là hình như là thày không
cần viết số nhiều gì mà
ở ngoài không biết rồi nhiều nó nhưng sẽ
tạo về học phí
hot girl chạy qua những cái file này nó
ok rồi
anh em mình sẽ có 1 thư mục và thư mục
bền ăn đi nha sau đó hai bên này thì sẽ
là Order cần trả lời à
khi sex
à a wifi ở thực ra tôi bảo mấy phải thức
sai xóa đi
nhà đất Đà Nẵng à
quanh trên
lỗi tội lỗi tôi
em còn trả lời thôi ra chả có gì cả Có
khi bỏ qua được
Ừ nhưng mà khuya là mấy ông lên tạm một
cái Excel kế thừa controller đấy tốt
nghĩa là kế thừa một cái cắn chết đó
tổng thì tốt tôi cứ tạo lại cái con sơ
tổng cái đi ừ
profession Index này
à à
dạy mấy ông là mình sẽ tạo một cái con
chắc ở trên này trước sẽ là mình sẽ
ờ ờ con chắc ở đây thì làm gì sẽ đây có
làm một cái cổ tích thật Hifi vết cũng
được Mày biết à
I wanna
mua đồ
anh ạ
đi dạo trách à
Bà mình sẽ à
sơ đồ logic
à à
ở đây nhà đi
thế này sau đó thì mình chỉ cần lấy dữ
liệu ra đây mình sẽ là ta làm Jeep mua
đồ ghét lấy toàn bộ tất cả về những này
Ô Ô Ngày cũng được tùy thì phải dùng
best Return view sẽ có là ờ ờ
xu hướng mặc định sẽ là video sẽ là amin
rồi ăn Min này à gì
chấm dorot Mua đồ này
à à
Ừ đợi tí nào Đợi tí nhé
vì thế đây không gửi tin được đây là
không phải mua đồ đây thấy bồ đi à
vẫn là áo rách 1 tháng mua đồ một khoảng
thời bồ
Âm Nhạc
anh em như nào cho tiện nhỉ Bởi tôi vẫn
muốn ở gọi thấy bộ dưới này cho nó tiện
là kiểu bằng Loser
không không cần mặc định thêm rồi đó
Biết web bizweb là nó luôn Chạy qua cái
hôm đấy Không cần phải thì không cần
phải thế mình đấy
à à
Ừ Ok Cứ làm tạp hóa vì đôi khi buổi trưa
Tôi đọc một cái bài nó đôi khi chúng ta
không nên làm thuốc tạp quá
5 phút ta quá cho những cái dự án đơn
giản mình tốn nhiều ra nó nghĩ nhiều
mang phí về sau mức công sửa lại chỗ này
một tí thôi không sao đấy nha
Còn không thì ông sẽ phải ông
Chỗ này cho nó tiện à đây cho Zip thuê
bồ bằng giờ
ăn Tết
à Có sao mày
thứ ngày
trò chơi tự ái cho nó tiện đi
à à
có thấy bồ của chú của mấy ông đấy à
anh ở đây sẽ chuyển tới địa báo ta
a a
ta
biết tại sao phải làm kiểu này không Để
với sau mình kiểu chỉ cần sửa lại ngon
Nghe máy đi à à
Em
định về sau mình chỉ cần à
vì sao mình chỉ cần sửa mỗi cái hàng mua
đồ ở trên này là có nhờ toàn bộ những
cái dưới này mình đỡ phải xưa không ạ
tiện sẽ có ở đây là
à một thư mục chứ nhìn tạo thêm một
nhiều lắm
ở nhà một lần chuẩn là con nhiều những
đầu sách cho ạ
a file max FPT này
tôi sẽ dùng là tôi sẽ dùng ta thấy bồ
các thứ thử nhiều đấy ạ
thế này à đội nó lại
à à
anh ơi
ở Masters
trẻ sơ sinh
này
em nó
không nội dung ở giữa của mình thì
à à
tin nhắn trước thôi
à cô này
hướng dẫn bật trước tại A
à à
anh ngày xưa có ai
a
this class is closed
à à
tiếp theo là
thế này với ông là muốn chat thì cũng sẽ
hiểu là cái cô 12 này tức là là đủ 12
tuổi còn thương ai chia đôi màn hình
mình thành 12 cô Xong hồi cầu để mà giao
diện điện thoại thì nó sẽ cậu có lại hay
cái gì đó rất tiện
em nghĩ cát à
ốp lát da body I xe
Honda ép mình phải có cái hết đồ nó nữa
cơ à à
xài 3
chị Linh Ở đây đá
nó là đâu
ở đây mình sẽ lên tiếp
và inbox e
ta lại sang
anh nói gì nhé
ừ ừ
ở nhà đỏ gọi quay Huy rồi con bé tôi
thay bồ vậy
ở
đâu này gọi thử Ghét đồ xong à
khi mà lỗi gì
xe
Jeep not in
Anh check contact
A lô tô user admin modifier
ờ ờ
bên này nó nghỉ à
Ừ em nghỉ như Tội Ác
Ừ ok ok rồi bấm vào đây
à à
thì bấm ở đây phải là
I mean You're enough
không Thôi nghỉ ở
ở gần đây
à
à à fix
ừ ừ
Ở đây có một ít vào đây Thôi đi về như
trong nó không đẹp lắm
anh ở đây tôi xem lại xem ma
à À bữa nó thường ai có một cái trên này
nữa cái trên này biết hai chùa nữa
có một cái đít ra ở trên một cái đi Thái
thở trên ở đây mình như thế mình à Mấy
méo nhớ về cái vụ Hồi trước tôi từng làm
hai thùng không sửa lại cho đại tí
em về nhà chưa Con bé này
Ừ cái stock ten
à à
rau này
em copy ở đây nhanh
Anh xóa cái
Ừ tôi giữ xóa cái này đi này hay khổ Đây
đúng ạ thì sẽ đưa hai tổ đây
à à
lên ở trên này luôn
Ừ anh Sơn La
đôla Thái Thu như hôm trước tôi bảo là
mình có thể truyền ở đây mình sẽ lấy tôi
có pik lấy ra ác nêm em
an
apple i
v-app này sau đó thì mình sẽ lấy lên
ba.net ngày cái này mình mặc định mình
sẽ luôn truyền ở trong căn các căn chữ L
ờ
Luân chia sẻ cày đây
sẽ dualit hai bộ luôn
à à
là
kết hết là sao có hai chữ cái đầu là
Capital ồ ồ
em có mấy chị nào truyền hình Thái thổ
có thứ thứ
à mà ở đây mình sẽ có cái 30 ạ có một
cái bàn
đã Ta thê bồ ở đây Thực ra là tôi lại
không thích
Ừ tôi không thích tao tao Thay bồ ôm chở
mày nữa
anh em kiểu đó dùng áo ra đi tại sao vì
mấy ông thấy hôm trước dùng ra Suite ở
đoạn dưới xử lý khá lằng nhằng nên là
bởi vì a với các bạn thì dữ liệu Tôi
đang ít tôi sẽ
hiểu như bình thường cũng có cái xuất có
nhiều thứ
em nói sao Ồ nhớ vẫn có cái số ở trên để
mà sót Nếu không màu sắc người ghi cụ
thể không Tôi sẽ dùng đấy con trai nhưng
thưa đây tôi sẽ là cái kia này
hình ảnh
cô gái sau đó đây mình sẽ có bạn nhưng
thường thôi thì sẽ là
mình sẽ copy cái này nhé
ừ ừ
Ồ tôi thích cái bảng 13 kiểu ngày 22
kiểu ngày trong bạn Chuyện này khá đẹp
này
là được à
mình sẽ có
pH đi rồi chọn chuyên nghiệp đi tối rồi
Ừ thế có là ai đi nè nêm làm cho nặng
thế
bạn mới thế này chưa Đã đó thì họ thích
cả đây này sẽ có là đa ta
một này em phối này à
à à
Anh hello
Ê Đê
tại sao cần thêm hai cái hẹn mấy cái thẻ
này để về sau nếu mình dùng Mà mấy cái
thu viện gì đó nó thường quan trọng của
cái t hết đây body cực
đây mình sẽ
ở đây mình
đi xe đây là đô la x gọi đến đi thôi
anh Hải xã hội cơ bản
trò chơi thử nhé
à Xong rồi
à vợ ơi
Vì sao đây võ diện rồi nhỉ
Ơ sao đấy vỡ hiện được
Ừ Nói tí
ờ ờ
anh đã bị cố định chiều cao
người lại
anh làm sao cố định chiều cao nhỉ
ừ ừ
nhỉ
anh sex video sex ai đây rồi
Nghe danh nhân
khi đốt này
à à
anh không hàn the body này
À không có gì để cố định chiều cao đây
luôn ý
à à
mời ông có gì mà không xem
em kiểm tra lại sau đây ạ con tra này có
cái phân trang không ạ Còn chán thì lại
bên ai
ờ ờ
anh cao nhiều lắm ngoài nữa
Ừ cái tin Iceland
không thích thôi thích cày
từ ngày chồng cái này được nhất này
nghe lệnh Copy toàn bộ Cái này đối ngoại
thương 3 các bạn này À thằng nào làm
ngon rồi
à à
Em chỉ cần A vào đây như này
đi xóa lại đi
ở
bến xe đây là
đô la data sau đó chị Linh là được
Ừ hình như thế
em trả lại
vì
vậy nhưng không đẹp lắm gì vậy à đúng ơi
tôi nhớ lần lần trước bảo là hình như là
do là mình chưa khai báo nó lấy bút
Chess
Cake I
d-expert
à à
xem nhé
a e cái nick này
I think we chat vậy
chị sẽ khai báo đây ra bê nashville pháp
service đ
nhiều nhỉ
rất nhiều bấm sao cho hai trong ba Ok
này đó tương đối ngay thôi
Ừ nó bị lỗi cái
a Hero
Ừ ừ tao bị nhầm lẫn này lỗi tội lỗi tôi
ở
tại sao giờ này cô Tâm đổi cơ bản nữa
nên này à
lỗi nó diện nó nghỉ học hỏi không có cái
đấy
Ừ ừ
đúng nhỉ Đây Rồi
lỗi gì không nghỉ à
mình sẽ hiển thị thêm vài cái thông tin
là thông tin các kiểu thứ ảnh hưởng sau
Đợi thì đợi tí
này
Nhưng mà không nói cho Hôm nay thì ra
tốn khá nhiều thời gian cho vụ War nhưng
mà hôm sau tôi sẽ đề cập trong mấy ông
không phải là ngoài việc xem thêm sửa
xóa bình thường nữa mà tôi sẽ đề cập cho
mấy ông về cái vụ này này nếu béo để kỹ
là tôi có nốt lại toàn bộ những cái sẽ
dạy ở đây sẽ dùng sắc form này kết hợp
với mua đồ một tí một vài cái tôi sẽ cho
mua đồ ra tôi không khuyến khích người
ông Dũng mua đồ nhiều cái Mua đồ là gì
thì hình như tôi từng nói mấy ông tôi
mua đồ WeChat này
Ờ Ờ
Nó là kiểu bấm vào nó sẽ hiển thị ra như
này hồi trước của tôi rất là lạm dụng
cái này để mà
thêm 2 xóa cái gì đó ông không phải nhảy
sang cái trang này mà gửi cho phóng thêm
là những sang Ford để update ông update
Bằng ngày khá nhanh nhưng nó sẽ có một
nhược điểm đó là ông không bác không
không quay lại được ông không bị điều
khiển quay lại được đây Và khi ông copy
cái đường link này gửi người khác không
được về Rõ ràng này khi mà tôi gửi cho
ông cái đường linh như thế này không ạ
thì làm gì có gì thì ra mua đồ nào đâu
trừ khi ông đẩy lên hai địa chỉ ở dạng
Mua đồ nha à Xong rồi ông lại bắt một ra
Speed để mà nhìn thấy mua đồ lên thì đấy
là một cách thôi chị một cách thôi Nhưng
mà ông điều hướng quay bác thì nó sẽ bị
mất cái dữ liệu điền trong cái Ford
model này chẳng hạn ông ông điều hướng
bác không quay lại không được Gà bệnh
đặc biệt với giao diện điện thoại thì
cái mua đồ đấy cả khó chịu và cả không
điều hướng quay lại nữa nên thành ra là
ở đi mua đồ này bây giờ lại ít được dùng
trong một vài tiếng cuống thì nó mới
hiển thị lên part2 bị lên một cái xóa
nhanh đi đó thôi đấy thì
Ừ thì chắc là cái việc khi mà thêm dữ
liệu thì tôi sẽ không dùng mua đồ con
update thì chắc là tôi có thể dùng tôi
cập nhật nhanh dữ liệu vào trong cái
hàng đấy cũng được Cũng được đấy Ờ tôi
sẽ có vụ lại import và export các thứ
bằng CP hơn gì đó đủ kia cho mày không
xe
nghe con nói với cả slot Nói chung là
toàn bộ những cái tôi sẽ dạy đây Đúng
rồi mà tôi sẽ nói qua mấy ông thấy thì
ra mấy hôm nay mấy ông nghĩ là tôi có
người đang cốt rất là chậm ngoài việc
không phải là
ở ngoài việc cả tôi đang cố tình trạng à
Tôi đang bị chậm không mà tôi đang cố
tình kiểu chậm một tí
anh theo kiểu là tại sao Vì tôi không
muốn làm hết sao chuyện đồng loạt cùng 1
lúc mà tôi muốn
giải thích kỹ mấy ông và đặc biệt là tôi
muốn là giao diện nên ít một tí tôi sẽ
làm nô cây notarization này reproduction
này theo bộ làm sao rồi ôm bà luôn Thế
là sao như tôi Tân bảo là mình sẽ có 3
ngôn ngữ tiếng Anh và tiếng Việt là cái
giao diện này mình sẽ hiển thị ra phong
từng anh nói tiếng Việt nghe toàn bộ
những cái này là ông đang hot cốt là
theo kiểu lên như này các bạn đây là một
cái cái này thứ mấy cái này cái thì ông
để tiếng Anh được nếu mà để tiếng Việt
nên phải đi tiếng Việt Hoàn toàn không ạ
Mình sẽ làm cái đấy như thế nào chậm
mình làm đấy như thế nào mà mình sẽ sử
dụng cài Pocket Nói chung sử dụng cái
Eriol đã hỗ trợ để mà kiểu nó khái niệm
đây này ông bên vi rồi mày ông sẽ có cái
la này mặc định nó còn ngữ tiếng Anh sẵn
ở đây rồi Ngay cả này có vai date này
mày nhớ Ừ có dịch hết toàn bộ này
ông sẽ phải
ba Tết này có bản tiếng Việt nhé ở mấy
cái này có bản tiếng Việt hết rồi đấy
ông thích thì chai trên mạng có ai leo
lên Xong rồi Việt Nam ít thì nhớ có ấy
tôi sẽ nói chuyện có thôi sẽ chẳng có
một ông nó đóng góp cái đấy rồi Nhờ đó
nói là mình sẽ làm hiệu để để cho đa
dạng ngôn ngữ nữa không ạ Mình sẽ làm đa
dạng ngôn ngữ những cái này để mà khi mà
hiển thị lên sẽ đúng theo mát mình muốn
có thể là ở bên admin thì mình để hết
toàn bộ tiếng Anh cũng được không sao cả
Không sao cả Nhưng ở bên khách hàng thì
mình sẽ cần mình sẽ cần phải ai mà chọn
tiếng Anh thì hiện đĩa Tiếng Anh ai chọn
tiếng Việt thì nó phải đến nghe tiếng
Việt đúng không ạ Đấy tôi sẽ hướng dẫn
buổi sau
số của mày gà thôi bị xuống cái đoạn au
Tôi không tự tin cho lắm để cốt cốt của
ông mà rất là ngắn nhưng nếu thấy rất là
ngắn
phải tự mò khác nhiều
Xin chào tôi mỏi chưa Chuẩn Xem lại vụ
đấy
ý tưởng này cho tặng thế đâu nhỉ thoáng
qua nha
cái gì vậy cha buổi sau
câu hỏi tôi tôi sẽ hướng dẫn làm mấy ông
về cái vụ api đó không cần lại rất hay
nhưng mà tôi dậy người ông đấy chứ ai
Tôi sẽ ngoài qua thềm lại một lần nữa
đây tay kết hợp việc à cách để sinh ra
một cái tài liệu theo api của mình rất
là hay đấy
dẫn cả là người ông có thắc mắc câu hỏi
gì thì ngoài việc với ông che chở lại ở
Chat trực tiếp ngay ở tôi trả lời nhiều
lúc rồi tôi không đẩy rồi bị trôi cho Để
sẽ để mày ông Nếu mà cần gấp thì mấy ông
đi inbox riêng tôi có thể qua qua bất kỳ
động được anh nhá chứ mày ông cha đây đó
bị trôi còn vài cái nữa trả Để hôm sau
rồi hãy trở nốt
như tự sinh tài liệu theo cốt mình và
mình sẽ mình sẽ hiểu biết để tạo ra tài
liệu hay phết cho mấy ông xem một cái
vài cái ví dụ gần đây Hồi trước tôi cậu
tương dung nó là thằng là
ex2 độ thông minh
ở nhà nghỉ
I was closed Walker nè ngon
ở đây ngoài việc kiểu tài liệu giấy nó
còn có bấm mà kiểu test ủng các thử tài
liệu ngon lắm
anh về sau vì sao tôi sẽ cho bé uống xem
lập trình viên mình có thể test cùng các
thứ thôi
Anh cũng chưa vào khuyên tôi dạy bằng
Java mời ông ngồi ngồi xem tôi mò bài
thêm nữa
Ừ nó chao bữa mày hiểu rồi là biểu với
ông nha
anh giải phết I